la levée des couleurs dans le ciel 10
you un moment que volodymyr zelensky
n'aurait manqué pour rien au monde
le président ukrainien a rendu visite
aux soldats qui ont permis la reprise de
ce territoire clé des mains des russes
lors de la contre-offensive et view la
scène est choquante mais cela ne me
choque plus car on a vu les mêmes scènes
abuja et dans les premiers territoires
libérés
ce sont les mêmes bâtiments détruits des
gens tués
l'ukraine a repris plusieurs milliers de
kilomètres carrés dans l'est du pays
autour de kharkiv est dans le sud vers
personnes depuis la russie ne cesse de
pilonner les forces du craignent haine
pour ralentir leur progression
dans la région de kharkiv dans les
régions de voris naba la kia et
confiance des frappes massives ont été
menées contre les troupes et
l'équipement militaire des 14e et 93e
brigade mécanisée des forces armées
ukrainiennes 150 soldats ont été tués et
blessés ainsi que plus de dix unités de
matériel militaire détruites un succès
qu'elle kiev doit beaucoup à l'aide des
états unis selon le new york times la
double contre offensive à kherson et
karkhiv a été préparé en amont avec le
pentagone au cours de simulation depuis
le début du conflit washington a livré à
l'ukraine plus de 14 milliards et demi
d'euros d'équipements militaires pieve
bénéficie aussi des renseignements de
bouteilles
les images des satellites d'observation
américain sont mises à disposition de
l'état major de kiev qui disposent ainsi
d'une vue d'ensemble de la situation en
quasi temps réel